Hopes, rumors, and then actual news of a movie
based on the long-running TV classic The Simpsons
floated around for years before The Simpsons
Movie was released in 2007.
It was worth the wait.
A hilarious animated adventure with a big
story befitting the big screen, the film made
more than $500 million at the worldwide box
office.
It's been 10 years since everyone's favorite
four-fingered Springfield residents proved
they could make the jump from television—so
how come they haven't made The Simpsons Movie
2 yet?
A good idea
The show's writers and producers don't want
to attempt another big-screen project just
for the sake of doing it.
It's such a monumental project, with millions
of dollars at stake and millions of fans with
exacting standards, that they'll only make
another Simpsons movie if they've got a really
good idea—one that's really worth a 90-minute
treatment.
During a Simpsons panel at the 2016 San Diego
Comic-Con, writer-producer Al Jean addressed
the possibility of doing another Simpsons
movie.
"We talk about it, but if we do it, we only
want to do it if it's going to be really good."
Already used it
At one point, the writers actually thought
they had a great idea for the next Simpsons
Movie.
In an episode initially conceived as the 24th
season finale, Kang and Kodos, the humongous,
booming-voiced aliens that have appeared in
numerous "Treehouse of Horror" Halloween specials,
kidnap the Simpson family from "Diz-Nee-Land"
and take them to their distant home plant
of Rigel 7, where Homer is nearly eaten.
Al Jean, who co-wrote the episode with David
Mirkin, decided with Simpsons executive producer
James L. Brooks that the plot was so ambitious
that they should use it for the next Simpsons
Movie.
Jean told Entertainment Weekly,
"...we were worried that people might think
it's an idea that's not canonical..."
—because the plot is so far gone from the
generally realistic scenarios of The Simpsons.
The script went back into the episode pile
and aired as "The Man Who Came to Be Dinner"
in 2015.
Too many ideas
Perhaps the real problem isn't that the Simpsons
writers don't have a good idea for a sequel…
it's that they can't pick just one.
For example, before they settled on the plot
of the first Simpsons Movie, the writers floated
several large-scale, movie-worthy concepts.
The fourth season episode "Kamp Krusty," in
which Bart and Lisa attend a terrifying, decrepit
summer camp that descends into nightmarish
chaos, was nearly a movie.
Matt Groening wanted to make a Fantasia parody
called Simptasia, consisting of short animated
sequences set to music.
And before his death in 1998, Phil Hartman
planned on making a live-action film about
his Simpsons character, B-movie actor Troy
McClure.
"He can talk, he can talk, he can talk, he
can talk!"
“I can sing!”
Matt Groening isn't thrilled
Any Simpsons movie has to get the sign-off
from Simpsons creator and executive producer
Matt Groening.
Even 30 years after his characters debuted
on The Tracey Ullman Show, he's still very
much involved with any and all major decisions
affecting his prized creation.
And as far as a sequel goes, he's in no rush.
Why?
The first one was a grind.
In a 2009 interview, Groening said the first
movie was an experience that left him "frustrated,"
in part because he and other members of the
creative team thought it would take two years
to produce but it ended up taking four.
While speaking at UCLA Law School in 2013,
Groening said that the first film, quote,
"stole animators from the show and drained
resources."
At the same speaking engagement, Simpsons
producer and director David Silverman estimated
that another movie would happen in "another
10, 15 years."
Busy Simpsons
James L. Brooks, a Simpsons executive producer
since the show debuted in 1989, told The Hollywood
Reporter that the Simpsons creative team hasn't
made another movie because they're "doing
a lot of other stuff."
Brooks meant that whatever time The Simpsons
makers have for work outside the show itself
is spent on Simpsons-related extracurricular
activities, such as a series of live Simpsons
shows at the Hollywood Bowl or developing
the scores of Simpsons bonus material for
the Simpsons World app.
"It's the all new Simpsons ride.”
“Happy times.”
The Simpsons is still on TV
Probably the main impediment preventing The
Simpsons' writers, cast, and crew from making
another Simpsons movie is The Simpsons.
The same people who'd make another movie are
already pretty busy making 22 episodes of
the show every year.
That's a huge workload—episodes take months
between conception and full animation, so
each is a lengthy and costly endeavor involving
a small army of employees.
Simpsons producer and director David Silverman
told Entertainment Weekly in 2017 that a sequel
is
"...daunting because it really knocked the
stuffing out of us to do the movie and the
show at the same time."
If the crew doesn't want to make a movie at
the same time as the show, don't expect that
sequel anytime soon.
The Simpsons has been renewed until at least
2019.
Fox hasn't ordered one yet
While another Simpsons Movie would be a surefire
hit and a no-brainer for all involved, the
fact remains that studio Twentieth Century
Fox hasn't technically asked for one yet.
The creative team isn't about to move mountains
to make another movie until they're officially
asked—and contracts are signed.
Otherwise, why work on something that might
not get made anytime soon—or ever?
Nevertheless, Simpsons writer-producer Al
Jean says a movie is in its "earliest stages,"
which probably means the show's writers are
tossing around ideas and getting a game plan
together for if and when their corporate bosses
ever commission a Simpsons Movie sequel.
Keep those stubby yellow fingers crossed!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!